[Applaudissements]
on servait doit bien ça le monde alors
gilles juste un mois malheureusement il
ya un problème est que le réalisateur
n'a pas bien vu ce que pour lui c'est un
plaisir sur la paix la voile avec plein
août le gars me dit avec plaisir mais
faut vraiment se montrer un beau et il a
les plus beaux poils du monde
attention jean michel maire soit qui est
du marché du lait qui est parti avec
bonjou pour ce faire sauter un petit
suisse dans sa bouche en tapant sur sa
main quel est le jeu le plus vieux
réfléchissez bien
les amours slam le juste prix aux mots
tu sais pas si l'un est injuste sans
hésitation ouais les amours sans
hésitation les armes sans aucune
hésitation sachez que ce n'est pas cela
m'a juste fait liste ça n'est pas motus
ça n'est pas les amours c'est le juste
prix du héros qu'il est sûr de lui sans
hésitation à lady essayé avec patrick on
n'en sort pas
attention magnifique on joue au jour
valérie bénaïm ce sera le dernier
valérie médaille qu'est ce que je fais
moi c'est l'animateur n'a jamais
présenté une émission sur tf1